young lives wanting change ignoring
calls to stay home because of
coronavirus determined to be heard
especially just to fight for equality
and just to get the word out to
everybody that we're here and we won't
change so many people have died I'm not
saying that people innocent things that
they've done in their lives but no one
deserves to die in that horrible way
like George Roy did his death under the
knee of a white police officer still raw
so they marched a Parliament Square up
beat no sign of violence Winston
Churchill back on display but with an
unusual guard after his and other
statues were targeted in Glasgow what's
becoming a familiar pose scuffles as
police try to control the crowds
demonstrators out in Manchester - I've
had mixed feelings towards it largely
positive because it is so good seeing
that the world in general is like yes
black guys do matter they do have value
based in Israel and we introduce and
think about it but at the same time I
worry that it's just a flash in the pan
and with so much focus being on George
Floyd I'm wondering if he's going to be
the face case for the next couple of
weeks then once people start caring
about him they start stop caring about
the movement in general
which is not what we want back in London
they don't want to lose momentum and
[Music]
[Applause]
carnival-like sometimes but the message
mysterious people want change the
swollen crowd gathers in Trafalgar
Square it's a movement that believes now
is their time Deborah Haynes Sky News